al caer la noche del sábado los
manifestantes franceses seguían en las
calles de parís tras una nueva jornada
de protestas contra el polémico proyecto
de ley de seguridad es un momento un
poco complicado porque hay cobit lo que
puede por supuesto justificar ciertas
medidas que restringen nuestras
libertades personales pero al mismo
tiempo nos parece que el gobierno ha
demasiado lejos en particular con el
derecho a la protesta en la capital como
en una decena de ciudades francesas las
manifestaciones fueron contra el
proyecto de ley de seguridad presentado
este otoño que penaliza la difusión de
imágenes de miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad desde noviembre este proyecto
despierta a la oposición de los
activistas de las libertades civiles y
de los sindicatos de periodistas esta
ley es muy opresiva y creo que es muy
grave a nivel democrático creo que es
importante que se permita filmar a la
policía sobre todo porque tenemos muchos
problemas de violencia entre las
personas que se unieron a las
manifestaciones se encontraban
activistas del movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos el colectivo también
contó con el apoyo de representantes del
mundo de la cultura
vinieron a defender su derecho a ejercer
lo que la gente se está movilizando por
muchas cosas al mismo tiempo y hoy
estamos luchando por el derecho a
protestar a angra de papel hacia las 17
horas una hora antes del toque de queda
nocturno impuesto por el cob y 19 hubo
enfrentamientos entre unos 50 jóvenes y
la policía después de recibir piedras la
policía utilizó cañones de agua para
desalojar la plaza